[Music]
so
hey you guys it's sunday
yeah we went out last night yeah we're
kind of sleepy yeah
it's pretty good yeah we got a good time
yeah we're gonna go out tomorrow night
too
yeah my poor liver is already going no
what are you doing to me lady i got the
new uh
puskin shirt on yeah that's the bigger
one the bigger one
yeah it's bigger it'll be better on some
of the larger shirts i like them both
the big one in a little one the small
one's kind of cool too big one
depends on how big you are and how big
the shirt is i guess
yeah i mean you couldn't put the big one
like on a baby shirt yeah we never
didn't make any baby shirts
nobody's asked for it didn't even occur
to me until just now they're out there
[Laughter]
yeah we thought about i did think about
making pookie a 13 o'clock
little sweater shirt or something yeah
she wouldn't she wouldn't wear it
so we got badger in there my boy louie's
there
deborah esther's in esther esther's in
there yeah
i called her asher yeah sure yeah that's
enough
all right um yeah we watched uh
we watched some movies uh the other day
sinbad movies
tila one of our listeners brought up
sinbad her
uh uncle was telling her that if you
really want to see good movies you got
to see the sinbad movies
and uh i forgot all about those things
we saw them con about five years ago
some of them yeah and uh
you know they're ray harryhausen he did
special effects on them
and the last two are british i don't
know i don't think the first one was
british
everybody sounded american in it yeah
well there was kind of a large
uh gap between i mean the first one
which was seventh voyage just in bad
that came out in 1958
yeah and then the second one golden
voyages and bad didn't come out until
1973.
yeah and i saw i saw a golden voyage of
sinbad
and sinbad in the eye of the tiger yeah
we're gonna have to we were gonna watch
all three of them but we didn't have
time
so we'll probably watch eye of the tiger
tonight and talk about that tomorrow
what i was saying is i saw them both in
the
in the theater i suppose yeah my
babysitter took me to scene when i was
little kid
the famous kimmy the famous kimmy that's
my first girlfriend
i was just in love with that girl she
ran off with a teenage dude that had a
car
that was something else i was standing
out there and jaw dropping
she got into the car with him and they
wrote off [ __ ] mike my buddy mike who
was like a couple years older than me
he's like
you stole your girlfriend man if jimmy
goes it's cause he's got a car
that was [ __ ] funny it's hard to look
cool putting a 13 year old girl in the
back of your big wheel
yeah yeah she wasn't 13 by the time that
happened
i think she was about 15 or 16 by the
time that happened that was probably
about
eight or nine that's probably about nine
or something maybe
maybe maybe i might have been tan you
know but that's [ __ ] funny
looking back on that [ __ ] but anyway
these movies here
were uh they're good they're real good
they were kind of like
kind of like star wars before star wars
they had this we're going to take you on
a journey kind of tone to them
and they did they even even the 1958 one
kind of did take you into another world
now it's dated
but it's not that dated it was it was
ahead of you know for 58 it does real
well
it looks amazing um you know that
design's beautiful obviously ray
harryhausen is a [ __ ]
legend yeah and all the monsters and
stuff he comes up with
and this one like the cobra lady and the
[ __ ] cyclops and the dragon all this
looks so [ __ ] cool and honestly like
um
sinbad fighting the skeleton yeah in
this
that was uh probably the most popular
sequence and that's kind of what
inspired him to do like
you know in jason in the argonauts where
he was like fighting all the skeletons
because everybody just thought that was
so cool looking
yeah the first one is very much kind of
like jason and the argonauts
jason of the argonauts and the sinbad
movies you could there's some crossover
there
it's the same kind of movie uh
there's something about these movies
that they kind of remind me of the
haunted house at disneyland
they're just scary enough to make him
fun for a kid
yeah they don't overwhelm a kid but then
for an adult they are very fantasy
and there was sexual undertones in
everything that adults could appreciate
kids could appreciate it like it was
just
hot women in like ig with genie outfits
and the second one had uh caroline
caroline monroe and if you know anything
about carolina road is it
she had to be in these [ __ ] yeah they
had to put the put her in the top that
like
pushed the boobs together like that yeah
she's just breastfed
she was cute man real cute kind of a
real tan dark-skinned kind of british
girl i don't
i don't know if she was italian or part
italian or something i thought we
established that that she was
not somebody somebody said that she
might have been a part italian yeah i
think she was yeah she's just super cute
and um they just knew what they were
doing with them
well it's just a fun like epic adventure
yeah we're gonna see movies with romance
and there's
buckling and yeah yeah and there's
everything's gendered you know it's very
boy girl you know which that was cool
that's what that's what you wanted in a
movie like this
you know very uh
kind of adventure they're put you can
see
how much indiana jones was ripping off
of these movies too when you watch it
you go like that's where
that's where lucas and spielberg were
were coming up with a lot of these ideas
for star wars and a lot of these ideas
for
indiana jones you know with the traps
and
you know it's just cool real quick a lot
of that too is like from cereals
from the 30s and stuff yeah but i really
think
i really think uh indiana jones also
looked you know
the guys working on that of course
looked at these movies mighty had a lot
of the same people working on them
because probably they did um i think all
of the movies as far as i know like i
said we
we're gonna watch i the tiger because i
think that was the first one i saw that
came out in 77
and i'm pretty sure i saw that at the
drive-in um
but i think these first two were shot
in spain but they were done it was
columbia pictures though
yeah like all of them were now just
joined in we mentioned tea
earlier that you know she her uncle was
wanting her to watch these and that kind
of reminded us and that's been able to
see him again
but she's in there she just chimed in
she goes they got hot men
in them too so i guess she just saw
uh yeah the woman's got a [ __ ] call
and give a shout out to the hot men
that are i understand i totally
understand they're very gendered stories
swashbuckling handsome men
and they got ugly men too but even the
[ __ ] tom baker knocks it out of the
park
and he's in the golden voyage he plays
the bad guy he plays the bad guy
he's just like oh man he did a [ __ ]
fantastic job as cora
yeah i would recall so i wouldn't really
call tom baker a good looking guy but
he's for some
reason very good looking and compelling
in this as a [ __ ] villain
yeah it's like it's really really funny
because you know obviously you think of
him as doctor who but
like he he makes a really really good
bad guy
i think he's a better bad guy than a
doctor who almost you're like yeah maybe
that's
i think it was kind of a situation where
maybe
maybe he didn't want to play too many
bad guys could be easy for him to get
stu
type cast as a bad guy like arnold
arnold is much better as a villain
yeah much better he just didn't want to
play that one he knew that that's why he
didn't he didn't want to be a villain
because that's the route he would have
gone
yeah and you can't you can't carry a
movie as a villain
yeah your career goes away you always
get defeated yeah well i'm like
yeah you get typecast into like playing
that but
yeah so well the interesting thing about
the first one like you said it's
it's weird because the first one which
came out in the 50s
um you know the i think the first ray
harryhausen that i saw that i was aware
that it was ray harryhausen
was i mean i'm pretty sure i saw eye of
the tiger in the drive-in when i was
like five or six years old
but i wouldn't have been aware that that
was you know the guy doing the special
effects or whatever
but when i saw clash of the titans in
1981
um with just those as i love that
[ __ ] medusa
you know thing and like the [ __ ]
scorpions
and you know the little mechanical owl
and all that kind of stuff that was so
[ __ ] cool
and uh i think so i think that was kind
of my first movie that
i knew that it was ray harryhausen and
so i went out like looking for other
movies he had made
because obviously he made a bunch of
monster movies like in the 50s like what
uh 20 million miles to earth and all
that kind of stuff where he made like
dinosaurs and whatnot
and t says these movies had us cracking
up but they're truly good
and to create these movies must have
taken forever oh yeah
and um mango said they took about three
years to make
they had really good um costumes
and badger says don't get me started on
caroline
yeah she's [ __ ] i she was like a
notable even at like the age of seven or
eight when i was first seeing it i was
like god she's hot
she was real easily um and then fourth
throat
down says tom baker always plays a great
uh lunatic
and he did uh i need to check him out
playing russ putin all right
yeah i did really i don't think i ever
saw him yeah yeah louise the first time
i saw caroline monroe's and captain
chronos vampire hunter yeah i think that
i saw her in
uh she was in star crash she was in one
of the bond movies too wasn't she i kind
of feel like
i'm pretty sure she was i think she was
a bond girl yeah
but um if you like these movies you also
want to see
um the um jason in the argonauts movie
uh and uh i think there's a couple of
those yeah i mean
that like the greek version of this yeah
like him fighting those skeletons that
you feel like one of the best and in any
stop-motion animation
the giant [ __ ] stone of giant was a
bronze statue yeah
they're kind of old but they were good
um
and then you want to see clash of the
titans the old one that was yeah
yeah 81. man i saw clash of the titans
so many times i think i have that [ __ ]
memorized at this point and yeah the
kraken looked [ __ ] great yeah
now for t if you want to see old greek
type movie that has hot guys in it you
want to see
uh the ones that had [ __ ] um what was
steve reeves in it all the hercules
all the hercules movies with steve
reeves they were good they were kind of
like clash of the titans and jason the
argonauts they were about like that
level
they were older though they're kind of
hollywoodish you know i think it was 50s
right 50s and 60s
yeah but steve reeves was kind of like
the very first arnold schwarzenegger i
mean he was
he was a big dude bodybuilder um
he was not natural but he wasn't as
reuted out as like somebody from the
1970s
uh they were messing around with some
prototype anabolic steroids at that time
but reeves
[ __ ] looked great he was and
everybody liked him he was evidently
like a real good guy
um yeah there was a ton of hercules
movies was there was a series with steve
reeves and then there was a couple of
there was some italian ones like with
some other actors i think they were with
mickey hargitay as well steve reeves had
that
leading man kendall look but he was
[ __ ]
buffed out and uh they weren't afraid to
show his upper body i mean you know
[ __ ] he wasn't you're not talking
about like
charlene heston charlene heston was all
all barking no bite this [ __ ]
had some bite
he could whip your ass he's in good
shape
yeah esther said mst3k did a bunch of
the hercules movies yeah they did
hercules against the moon men
uh [ __ ] man they did like five or six of
them
i think yeah i remember that i remember
the moon man one
now i haven't seen eye the tiger in a
long time we're gonna see that tonight
yeah i remember i the tiger being the
best out of them all in terms of scope
and just quality
i have to say like the first one i love
the first one because i love
um the funny [ __ ] about his little
girlfriend getting shrunk down and him
carrying her around like a little pepper
shaker thing
yeah like it's a little well it's like a
little house that he makes for and she
goes down into the layout to talk to the
g
to the genie i will try master i will
try
that's cool they gotta put a candy in
there i love it
at least that kid wasn't as annoying but
the funny thing about it is that
one of my favorite things about that
movie is that there is this vague
prophecy
about freeing the genie and
you know the the princess parisa her
name is right
like after she gets like envigoned like
back to her normal guys
yeah that ought to be like a that would
be like a like a fetish [ __ ] thing
the invigoration yeah that's some chick
and she gets bigger nevermind
yeah i got i got went off on that well
see now i can't now i lost my
unless my lost my train of thought
because you're like just keeping it i
don't know
but um yeah so she gets back and beg it
and big end and there's there was kind
of a thing about
freeing the genie yeah and so and it was
really vague but she was like oh i think
the prophecy means that i have to throw
the lamp
into this lava yeah how'd they get that
and then
i was like well you better hope that
freeze the genie otherwise you burn that
little candle
inside and you'd be like no that stopped
bad it worked
but it worked well yeah that would have
been a really really different ending
shows that back on sin bed persian's
ship
and he goes oh by the way i brought all
the treasure i'm like oh he bought the
treasure it's a happy ending yeah
okay yeah he's like whoa we have a new
cabin boy and we're rich as [ __ ]
well i guess sinbad doesn't really give
a [ __ ] he's already rich as a
[ __ ] when he starts all these
voyages with the lord
sinbad that's true you know prince in
bed
is like oh more treasure
yeah but you know it's what this one i
think watching the first one like i said
it has so much cool [ __ ]
i love the cyclops uh i love the cobra
lady
uh you know that the magician does it's
just like there's just [ __ ] great
[ __ ] in it
and you know the skeleton fight it's
just it's just him versus one skeleton
but in this there's a dragon too in
there yeah there's a fire breathing
dragon
yeah they were using it as a guard dog
yeah they were using it as a gate
yeah it's just basically a gate and me
and jay were like where's this thing
[ __ ]
yeah it's like you think there'd be a
massive pile of [ __ ] right like right
because he couldn't go very far he was
on like a little choke chain
so you have to clean out that [ __ ] you'd
have to clean out the dragon [ __ ] every
day
and then imagine what you had to feed
it's like the litter box
maybe it was just the dragon litter box
yeah maybe it wasn't
scoop it maybe it was just totally a
magical creature it didn't eat or [ __ ]
it was just something conjured yeah i
mean you know i have not been alive i
don't know
you know that's what well maybe just
because you know like in the second one
golden voyage isn't bad where
um tom baker like the the wizard he had
those little homunculus
things like this little flying and they
were just like magic he made him out of
like potpourri or whatever that was
autumn and it turned into leaves it
looked like potpourri but
he just made him out of that so i guess
they were just amazing so maybe the
dragon is just like a magical creature
too
yeah you know what i mean it doesn't
have to eat or poop or anything the
person was good
but it was very dated compared to the
second one
by the time the 70s rolled around they
had perfected that look
it seems like the film stock was better
quality
the color processes were brighter the
costumes were a lot better
um the scope of the movies was was a lot
bigger you actually kind of you kind of
were more likely to buy the locations
you could tell it was matte paintings
and stuff but it was okay though you
know the practical effects it worked it
had it has
has a charm to it you can kind of
suspend your disbelief
and go yeah those big statues do exist
you know up in those mountains and
um a lot of good effects and a lot of
good ideas they actually
showed you know tom baker as the damn
evil sorcerer what was his name again
and he's showing his buddy watch this
watch this and he makes it
makes it when it comes to life a little
homunculus little bat creature
like a man with bat wings i got a little
gargoyles what it looks like and he
flies around and he can like spy on
people
and he's like threatening it with
scissors and [ __ ] like look at it look
at it i control it and then he makes
friends with it and then it goes out
it's basically his
[ __ ] drone he can speak through its
eyes and hear it through its
ears and he can control [ __ ] he can do
all this sorcery it makes him older
though as he does
he loses his life i really like that
aspect of it because
it seems like in the first one like you
had a wizard in the first one too that
was trying to get the lamp back from the
uh from the cyclops because the cyclops
was like oh you dropped this i'm having
it bye
yeah and you know what i mean that he
took it in his cave so the wizard that
was trying and then he like went
here's another thing about the first one
though because the wizard
shrinks the princess right like in the
middle of the night
and then no one seems is it me or does
no one like twig to the fact that
obviously the one magical dude is the
one that has done that because they all
kind of go to him and be like
you're the only one that can reverse the
spell and he does end up reversing the
spell but they have to go like get the
eggshell from the rock
and all that that's not not the rock
like that person but like you know the
big mythical bird
with two heads um but oh but i was gonna
say in golden voyage of sinbad i think
my favorite sequence in that is when
sinbad
fights kali the statue like with all the
swords
yeah i heard i was like watching
something that
kind of showed how they did that and
basically
they had to so john philip law
uh who played sinbad in the second one
who was also pygar in barbarella and he
was in
danger diabolique uh which was the last
uh
mst that was on the sci-fi channel so
you know you might want to go check that
out
but uh he's he's a good looking dude so
i liked him as sinbad
actually um because he has like those
real intense like looking eyes i don't
know there was something about him that
i thought was really
kind of embodied that character but he
had to
sword fight two or three guys
with swords that were kind of like roped
together you know what i mean
like and then obviously ray harryhausen
had to animate
kali um who had what like six arms
so we had to remember like what the film
was go like what the [ __ ] sequence
was where the swords were going and
every single arm had to be moved
yeah like individual i think it took
like three weeks of like constant work
to do it
yeah this statue had six arms it's like
kali i think khalid for real
had four arms i've seen well there's
different versions of his versions
there's different versions they look
like kali and uh yeah
and and it was being worshipped by all
these little mini hulks
little little green that's right because
that's great because
i call them the skinny halls yeah and
they're walking around because they're
all green
they're walking around doing ape walks
like they're monkeys and [ __ ]
they're so primitive that they walk like
a monkey you know
which uh and their teammates mentioned
that in the
in the uh in the comments she's talking
about it right now she doesn't really
like the movies
but there's there's definitely like this
overarching theme of
real dramatic deaths and over the top
kind of
yeah they didn't and then they said it
didn't pull any punches not at all
those movies leaned into what they were
they knew what they were
it was fantasy theater they're putting
on
theatrical death you know deaths and
stuff that's what it
is you know magic and it was
it was they were not trying to give you
a
believable version of realism that's not
what they were trying to deliver
this was a show well even their
mythic tales i even saw a clip of a uh
interview with ray harryhausen and he
said almost that exact same thing he's
just kind of like you know you want it
to look like it's a real
creature but it's like this is a fantasy
film so you want to give it that fantasy
element you don't necessarily want it to
look entirely realistic
because you know it's kind of like this
other world that you're creating
yeah well that's why i kind of was
comparing the movies to kind of like the
haunted house at disney world or
disneyland yeah
it it's trying to be scary but it's not
realistic and it's kind of funny at the
same time but it is it does have a dark
tone to it you know i mean you're
enjoying the whole thing and that's kind
of what it is
they were they had elements of that and
indiana jones at the same time that kind
of tone
i really liked in the second one you
know where
sinbad is hooked up with the vizier and
the vizier has this damn copper helmet
on so you can't see his face because he
got burned up
and he's been trying to figure out where
this island is and he's got the pieces
and there's a painting on the wall and
then they
they hold up the shadow and they go oh
yeah there it is and it was giving them
kind of a location
yeah and i was that was like right out
of indiana jones with like
yeah the well of souls you know they
were looking for the temple of raw or
whatever you know
it was kind of like that you know it's
just like yeah i can remember it as a
kid i remember my reaction to it as a
kid in the theater it was like i was
like oh wow that's awesome
you know wow how'd they think of that
it's real simple now
yeah but in those days that was so there
was a lot of nuance to that you know it
was like wow that's a good idea
shadows and making a map and on the wall
and
it all lines up wow
like in another time that's my high-tech
high-tech retro
futuristic technologies that they had
which they have that in in eye of the
tiger too you know they're using
mixing machine and magic together to
make you know
metallic minotaur robots
you know i mean yeah i'm looking forward
to seeing that one because i think it's
been
because i think we watched the 1958 one
a few years ago yeah because i
remembered like you know the little
bitty princess in the
little thing and i was sitting there
thinking you'd think
because at one point when they were
fighting i think when they were on the
island like fighting the two-headed bird
or whatever
um i'm pretty sure that sinbad had his
little girlfriend in her little
you know her little pepper shaker pepper
shaker and uh and he's like just tucked
in the into the pants
and then he was like running around and
fighting and stuff and i'm like man
she's probably like
bouncing all over that knock it off god
damn it and then
in that scene this is awesome because
these movies were kind of for kids and
young adults really was the target while
this was going on they got some poor
dude lashed to a spit and the damn
cyclops was roasted
cooking alive
i smell delicious yeah sinbad eventually
gets him off of there
although it takes longer than it
probably should yeah that would have
killed a man
ultra low i guess he's like yeah i'm
slow cooking this [ __ ]
but get all this tender meat falling off
the bone i actually like
the the more i watched it the more i
felt bad for the cyclops because the
cyclops
look dude yeah he's a monster and stuff
but he was just like on an island
yeah the wizard came and like was kind
of [ __ ] with him the wizard
i will note dropped the lamp right
yeah and then the cyclops just went and
be like ooh finders keepers
you know what i mean and he took it and
then the wizard was just being an ass
and he's like well i have to go back to
the island to get my lamp back
and you know the cyclops he's just a
monster he doesn't know and then like
when they go back and they fight him and
then they [ __ ] poked his eye out and
then sinbad was like hey
cyclops cyclops and then made them fall
off the [ __ ] foot it didn't poke it
out it was they burned it that's not
cool
burned it with it yeah that's right with
the torch and he was going ah
i've only got one of those
i'd be dramatic too if somebody burned
out my one eyeball yeah he got killed
because he ran off the cliff
the only thing i didn't really like
about that is that evidently there was
more of them on the island and they
showed another one but you could
obviously tell it was the exact same
bottle
at least they could have made the hair
color different i think eventually
um or initially the because ray
harryhausen
actually helped writing the helped
writing these films you know what i mean
like him and
another guy like they co-wrote them and
his uh you know using his
dynamation which is what they called his
stop-motion uh
thing and i think initially there was
supposed to be
two cyclops fighting each other i think
was supposed to be the
climax but for whatever reason they
decided [ __ ] it
we're gonna do a dragon instead and i
think the dragon they used for this was
actually repurposed from one of his
older movies like not
it wasn't exactly the same but i think
he reused like some of the armatures and
stuff i also heard that the
um the cobra woman from you know the
the magic show that the wizard does i
think that they repurposed that armature
for medusa and clash of the titans but
i'm not entirely sure if that's true or
not
yeah um esther says um the men were men
in those movies i love the fantasy
aspects of the sinbad movies jason the
argonauts too yeah
like i mentioned it before the scripts
were very
uh what you would call today gendered
they were very traditional gender roles
uh which goes along great with the
mythic
fantasy tale um you see the men were
acting like men with male with all the
frailties of being a man like some of
them were drunks
remember that and [ __ ] they fell prey
to the damn poisonous river because it
tasted like wine and
some of them we're going to drink all
this some of them got [ __ ] pissed off
and desperate and tried to
try to kill tried to kill sinbad because
they hadn't eaten in a long time
um they killed the rock baby yeah you
killed the rock baby they also tried to
steal the treasure
so yeah they were they were all acting
like men
they're kind of not all necessarily good
man they're like a bunch of yahoos
and then um uh
sinbad um sinbad runs into it basically
a tavern owner who's trying to get rid
of his worthless [ __ ]
musician's son he said please i'll pay
you to take him on a voyage give this
[ __ ] some battle experience get
him out of here
i'll even give you this beautiful slave
girl you could have her you know that's
where carolyn monroe came from
he freed her you know what i mean so
that was sinbad being a good dude no i
don't believe in that [ __ ] you're free
you know you can sleep in my cabin but
you don't we don't have to do nothing
you know that could
he had had a dream about her you had a
dream about it because she had it
because she had that eye on her
eye on there so she was like significant
yeah she had a part of she was part of
like an
oracle thing you know oh when they
talked to the oracle the damn devil that
came out of the well
oh i liked that it scared me when i was
giving oh the makeup and then i love
that
yeah yeah like he's all like kind of
green and purple and he's got like big
horns and [ __ ] and then
during the fighting even they got carol
monroe in there she's really the only
woman in the movie
it would just have been a sausage fest
without her all right so you have to
have a woman in the damn movie
i think there are women as bad guys
every now and then but there wasn't any
good guy women
but also one scene like they're being
attacked by all these damn monsters and
the vizier who's you know doesn't have a
face he's actually
protecting uh uh carolyn monroe did you
notice that
yeah yeah he's like he like and he's
like in this dramatic pose like
you have to kill you have to you kill me
to get to her which is that's all
you know great traditional values of you
know
courage and bravery and self-sacrifice
and
helping women and and and they
also i liked how they did it in a they
did it in a in an eastern tone these are
persians
tales i think they're actually
pre-islamic i'd have to check but
i was under the impression that that
that that uh
sinbad goes back before islam but uh
in the movies uh sinbad
is is is is muslim so they use a lot of
references to allah and
they never really talk about islam per
se
but yeah it is you know he says stuff
like trust in allah
[Laughter]
so that's good that they added that in
there you know they kind of
had uh i guess you could you would call
it a uh
abrahamic uh abraham the
the abrahamic religions uh their
versions of
of honor and morality which that that
that is true you know most
most of uh the abrahamic cultures
do have tales that are like that you
know what i mean yeah i mean these types
of like epic adventure tales pretty much
span the globe it's just kind of like
different cultural differences i was
gonna say you know what's interesting
though
the one uh so the golden voyage which is
made in 1973 the one with caroline
monroe in it
it was almost kind of like because i
don't i don't remember her
being because like you said i think i
she was more like a damsel in distress
type of character
yeah but in the first one in 195 the
1958 one
uh parissa did a bunch of [ __ ] like to
help she and after she got shrunk down
like she didn't even [ __ ] about being
shrunk down she was like oh bummer
and then he just put her in a little box
and carried her around and she was all
like chipper and everything
but he got uh she got them out of the
cage like he
she climbed out of the cave cage because
she was little and like pushed the
thing out of the lock and she went into
the um
the genie bottle or the genie lamp
and uh you know made a bargain with him
like and said hey we'll free you if you
help us do this
if you give us the words like to call
you and [ __ ] like that so she was a lot
more proactive in the 1958 one now that
i'm thinking about it there's another
good carol monroe movie that's
british that's kind of like this it's
called journey to the center of the
earth
yeah yeah yeah and she plays the
subterranean woman that
they found down there it's pretty good
you find all these
people that are being controlled by
these damn psychic pterodactyls that's
the best way to describe
is it's got peter cushing in it it's and
uh
it's all scary what's that doug mcclure
yeah it's all steampunk they i love that
movie they use a damn
drill ship it's like a train with
tractor treads on it a big old drill and
a big drill on the front yeah it's back
in the 1800s and it's all steam powered
and they go down
underneath the magma and everything it's
pretty cool it's pretty cool i don't
know that one in theater
i do like the psychic pterodactyl yeah
it's not as nice as these
no but it is fun i think they did that
on the new mst like mst the return the
netflix one
i'm pretty sure they did journey to this
end of the earth on that yeah because i
think that's because i saw it recently
and i think that's when i saw it i don't
remember if land the time forgot i don't
remember i don't think that had carolyn
monroe in it did it
some of you guys might know there were
there was cuties in it there was british
cuties in it but i don't think it had
caroline monroe
yeah um but yeah it's just
i mean all these are so fun and like i
said you really just can't beat
[ __ ] really good stop-motion
animation just because you can see
how it's so labor-intensive and you
really have to
be you have to admire like the [ __ ]
work and effort that goes into it
i mean ray harryhausen i think when he
was a kid and he saw
king kong you know in 1933 or whatever
it was called at earth's core
oh okay yeah that's what it was it
wasn't journey to the center yeah that
was called earth's core
yeah or maybe that is that two separate
movies i thought there was a journey to
the center
there is but i i might have been the one
with the pterodactyls the ones i was
thinking of that had carol monroe i
think was called
earth's core i think yeah yeah maybe
been a long time
megan said that was made by amicus i
didn't know that they're the ones that
made all the uh horror anthologies
they were like the other british uh
studio like
it was hammer who made all the gothic
stuff and then amicus
mostly made um you know anthologies
that's not all that they made but they
also uh there was there was the other
one that had the damn u-boat
what what did i call it uh the land that
time forgot that then somebody said you
got to watch the people that time forgot
that's like the sequel oh i don't think
i've ever listened we haven't seen that
one
i've heard it again yeah yeah we just
watched the one with the submarine not
too long ago
yeah that one was actually good yeah i
quite liked it yeah
but yeah so so ray harryhausen like i
said he saw king kong when he was a kid
and obviously the original king kong
from 1933 that had
stopped that was also stop-motion
animation and he was just so
taken with it that he's like i'm gonna
learn how to do that
and i mean the [ __ ] today it's still
like [ __ ] brilliant looking like you
said it doesn't look
you know realistic but it has its own
thing to it it has its own like charm to
it and it's just
i mean there's still i i saw like a
bunch of i was watching a bunch of other
youtube
uh you know reviews of it and there was
this one kid
who was probably like in his 20s and he
was just going on and on about like all
the sinbad movies and ray harryhausen
and it's just like he was really really
knowledgeable about it and like see
it's it doesn't have to you know it's
not just because we're old or whatever
it just seems like
because even like younger people can
appreciate the [ __ ] artistry that
goes into
because like i said how [ __ ] long
that takes it was i would call this
classic
british cinema okay yeah they're
theatrical all right uh
great sets good acting uh interesting
scripts
um the idea was to really entertain the
audience
it was to give the audience what they
wanted uh take them on a journey
it was just and it was everything was
classic everything was epic
it had an epic tone to it they knew what
they were doing they knew exactly and
they were very very tight edits
very tight they didn't waste time
although if they wasted time they wasted
time on a scene that
showed you something yeah like when what
like when
like when tom baker forms that
humunculus
yeah and then interacts with it a really
kind of a waste of time they didn't do
anything for the story but you love that
scene
well yeah because you're being drawn
into it as a kid i was totally mystified
by the little gargoyle creature you know
in its reaction
like to be prodded with scissors and
[ __ ] like hey leave me alone
and he makes fun and then he makes
friends with it and that sends it out
the window
sorry i poked it yeah yeah now you have
to now you have to do my bidding well
he's an evil sorcerer you know what i
mean i i run you i
[Laughter]
he animates the damn wooden statue of
the woman on the front of the damn ship
and he gets in the boat and starts
fighting how are you gonna fight that
it's just a piece of wood see that's
what i was like that when we watched the
first one and like sinbad was fighting
the skeleton i'm like
why even bother like trying to sword
fight with the skeleton because it's
like it's
you can't stab them yeah you have to
smash that you just have to like yeah
because that's like all you can do it's
just pointless like sword fighting it
i'm looking forward to see either the
tiger yeah in a long time
mega badger said he thought it was the
weakest one because he didn't think the
acting of the story wasn't quite as good
i remember the visuals being really good
though i remembered it looking better
than
um than than the second one
well we'll see in the golden voyage i
mean all of these are
amazing looking all the costumes are
amazing looking the monsters are cool
you know they're just cool like epic
stories and like you said
they don't really like [ __ ] around it's
always kind of like even like the 1958
one
you know they're on the boat they're on
colossa there's a cyclops like within
like the first [ __ ] five minutes i
think yeah
they show you something right off the
bat yeah and then it's just
going on and on and it's like there's
always like something cool to look at
the mango says there's some semi-nudity
in in the second one too
like in the third one yeah in the third
one oh
now tom's getting all excited yeah
because these all these aren't um
you know they call them like a loose
trilogy and they actually do i think
they sell them as a box set
um but they're not like they're
standalones yeah they're standalone
movies you don't have to like watch them
in order
or anything and they all have different
directors and they all have different
actors
playing sinbad and playing all the other
roles they're just kind of like
you know because it's sinbad was just
like a character and he was in like a
whole bunch of different
you know stories like going back
centuries and uh so they're just
adapting those like i said it's kind of
like greek mythology but yeah
now if you like these movies for me this
these movies kind of set the
tone and the bass line for sinbad
if you like these you probably won't
like any other sinbad movie especially
not from the time
because the other ones were russian
ripoffs that didn't have anything to do
with sinbad
yeah just re-edited as a sinbad and
that's not sin bad that [ __ ]
are russian
you can tell blond-haired blue-eyed
scandinavian sinbad yeah
wearing russian traditional clothing or
[ __ ] iceland or
finnish clothing and stuff like where
the hell are we why are we
why are why is it snowing you know yeah
it's like how is this
man yeah this isn't persia yeah why are
ice goddesses [ __ ] appearing out of
nowhere you know well yeah that's why
and and the funny thing is that um
because mystery science theater did one
uh i can't remember what season it was
maybe season four or five
uh i think it was the magic voyage of
sinbad and
it was obviously like i said it
obviously didn't start out as a sinbad
movie it started out as a
russo finnish uh you know folklore
story that was just acquired by some
you know american or british production
company and said hey we're gonna make
this into a sinbad movie
even though it's clearly not i mean it's
yeah it's a sailor and he goes on
adventures and there's like monsters
like
actually i think magic voyage of sinbed
has that really cool
uh bluebird of happiness like that which
is like a
it's like a big blue bird with like a
woman's head and it's actually pretty
cool looking yeah
um but it's like so it has like some
similarities to send bad stories but
it's really not
i don't know of any other sinbad story
like the whitest ass
[ __ ] bad you've ever seen if you like
these
if you like these you also like the
jason and the argonauts that had raised
ray harry housing in them you'd like
that clash of the titans from the
from the early 80s yeah man you would
like at earth's core
you'd like uh land of time for god
probably the people of time forgot i
haven't seen that one but
the land of time forgot kind of reminded
me this also um
strawdog 78 said didn't lou ferrigno do
a sinbad movie
no he did it i i don't was it sinbad no
i thought he did the i thought he did
like uh um
hercules well yeah he might have done
hercules but he might have done it's
been bad too i don't know
i have to look back at him interesting i
haven't they would have had to dub him
because he you know he sounds deaf yeah
the only only time his his his actual
voice worked was in that episode of uh
star trek continues where he played that
orion yeah ryan slave master that came
back
slave girl yeah and he just because he
sounds like he's an
alien talking and that worked worked
real well yeah he can act a lot of
people don't realize
it lou ferrigno can act it's just that
he has that slight speech and punishment
that
deaf people have yeah but he put on a
great show
and he's [ __ ] big he's bigger than
arnold for he's on
he's only a couple years younger than
arnold but he looks a lot younger
yeah yeah he's in a lot better condition
it's a well i was gonna say since we're
talking about voices
i found it very interesting that in the
first sinbad movie from 1958 everybody
sounded like americans right yeah
because like i said it was columbia
pictures
and then in the second one golden voyage
of sinbad they actually got like john
phillip law
decided he was gonna do a middle eastern
accent which i guess the director was
like not too jazzed about but he's just
like whatever you do you man
and um which you know it's fine i said
at least they tried to make it seem like
middle eastern like where it was instead
of just everybody talking like they were
from dubuque or something
but um you know and tom baker does uh
does an accent like that too but
it's i think it's more successful when
he does it
but again esther didn't know that lou
ferrigno's deaf yeah he's deaf
yeah he can talk though he can read lips
i think he can hear a little bit
but yeah i didn't think he was complete
i don't think he's totally deaf but he
does have that
you know my cousin's deaf and he can't
talk at all and then i've known other
people that were deaf they can do pretty
well but they you know they don't quite
enunciate things the right way
yeah because they know they can't hear
it they can't hear what they're saying
they don't they can't hear what they
can't hear what other people sound like
so
they'll have these little funny like d
and t
or the same sound that kind of stuff you
know
yeah i mean you know but yeah i just i
yeah i didn't think he was completely
deaf i thought but i thought he was
pretty
like his hearing is pretty bad yeah t
i've never seen people at time forgot
but
the land that time forgot i liked it i
liked it they said people that time
forgot had patrick wayne in it he was
the same guy who played sinbad
in eye of the tiger okay so there we go
all right it's a small world it's that
same kind of tone
same kind of movie that one i don't
think has any uh stop motion in it
but uh atlanta time forgot i liked it
evil samurai
and nazis and [ __ ] cavemen and it's
like
some it's like a frankfurzetta painting
or they try to they try to get that
it's a hollow earth story yeah
which if you understand german science
fiction german science fiction
always had hollow earths in it and a lot
of the
a lot of the guys who ended up in the
nazi party had grown up
reading german science fiction a lot of
the nazi party
thought of their motifs and a lot of
things that they did they got from
science fiction
a lot of people don't realize that and
there's a reason why they did that and
it's because
the communist party in russia
a lot of what they did they got from
science fiction
they were getting it from h.g wells and
uh what are the other ones jenny uh
julesburn jules bern
marx's communist theory
and their art and their motif
was very jewels jules vern
and uh science fiction you know what
they're doing
so when the germans do it they're not
going to use
foreigners you know what i mean they're
going to use germans so they went
use german science fiction louis said
lou ferrigno did play sinbad
he didn't bad at the seven seas 1989 89
yeah we're gonna have to see what if
it's any good i'm skeptical
every every every sinbad movie i've seen
outside of these i didn't like them
all right they just weren't right but if
somebody knows a good one just you know
drop in the comment section
you know later and i'll try to check it
out i'm skeptical of sinbad
it's like i guess i guess
like after you grow up seeing that
original clash of the titans
you can't redo that again and you just
can't recapture that
yeah it's like i saw the remake and it's
like it's not a terrible movie but it's
just kind of like it doesn't have that
charm
you're right of the first one yeah that
original clash of the titans which is
great i mean they're very untouchable
i mean the first one had all this
[ __ ] great person [ __ ] lawrence
olivia it was you know versus meredith
was in it and it was just kind of like
there was [ __ ] pegasus and medusa was
[ __ ] awesome yeah and it has that
theatrical tone that like these movies
had
yeah you could tell it wasn't they
weren't
trying to they were trying to take you
into a parallel universe not it was not
realistic
yeah uh and that was that's what made it
great
yeah because it was like i said it was
transporting you yeah it's taking
somewhere else
it's taking you away from this world and
taking you into another one
yeah and i think that's what i was
really liked about it yeah but yeah
that's what that's what these are like
too it's like all the
[ __ ] big rooms full of treasure and
like everybody's cool outfits and
snake ladies and yeah giant statues
coming to life
so t i would also recommend if you like
this or check out the jason
the jason and the argonauts i don't know
how many of them there are there's at
least
which a lot of people think is the best
movie that ray harry hasn't worked on
easton and the argonauts yeah yeah i
mean that skeleton fight i think there
might be more than one of those huh
i don't remember i mean this mostly
everybody just talks about that main one
okay but i mean ray harryhausen did a
[ __ ] ton of movies
jason the argonauts was like this except
it was greek
the motif is greek yeah it's super cool
so we just watched that not too long ago
yeah
probably a couple years ago i thought
there was a couple of those though
yeah maybe but like i said i don't
remember
i just i remember the first one like
fondly but i don't really remember
you know with the skeleton and the big
like creaking one of my favorite things
is when that big uh
that big statue comes to life and i love
the creaking noise that makes like the
sound effect
oh i wanted to say too that i think the
first um
this first sinbad movie the score for it
i think was done by
um bernard herman the guy that did the
psycho music
i'm pretty sure yeah oh so mango just
said that hitler was hiding in the
hollow earth
yeah i forgot why i was talking about
german science fiction
they had a hollow earth theory that went
back
into the 1800s with with a book called
uh real the coming power sometimes it
was translated as real the coming race
and they believed in these people living
in a hollow earth that you could
that there was a place near the pole
where you could go inside
and then there was another world of like
the earth was just a hollow shell
that's that's my understanding of it and
there was another chocolate bunny and
there's another sun in there and
everything you know it's just a crazy
concept
and um and they were using power
they were using this power called real
real was kind of like the force
but you can make machines that ran on it
and uh that's why
the germans were there's all this that's
why some of that stuff you guys were
talking about the nazi belt
legend of this bell with the blue light
coming out of it
a modern explanation is was well it's a
hoax when they're trying
they're trying to say that the germans
built a
uh ion propulsion engine but an
alternate explanation is is now somebody
made up a hoax saying that the germans
had discovered
vril yeah that you know that frill was
kind of
kind of real energy was kind of
described as
light and in plasma you know
so i think maybe there's a chance that's
why i don't believe in the nazi bell
story i think that it started off as
somebody's
saying that the [ __ ] not that the
nazis had figured out how to make vril
and through the frill you could have any
gravity and that's where you get all
this [ __ ] for like flying
nazi flying saucers although they did do
things like stealth craft flying wing
aircraft
you know they had that they had
something that was kind of like a flying
flapjack we had one of those too
which is kind of like a helicopter but
it had propellers on it like an airplane
but you could take off from almost a
standstill
with the thing it had so much wing area
we had a lockheed martin plane that did
that it was pretty neat but um
yeah so that movie that was talking
about land that time forgot and the
people that time forgot
was like based on german it's an english
movie but it's based upon
german science fiction that's why
there's nazis in it
they did uh there was a movie on mst uh
you know that came out in the 50s maybe
like late 50s the mole people
that was also based on hollywood it's
like where they fell
in this they went up to [ __ ] where
the [ __ ] were they
and oh my god i didn't remember where i
remember the name of the mountain was
kuitara
yeah and they fell down into the earth
and that's where like all the [ __ ]
there were all these people down there
that were like super super pale and then
they were like had all the
people like that that were their slaves
like now when you get on all these
hollow earth science fiction movies
including land of time forgotten
everything and it gets very convoluted
and scientifically impossible
just stop thinking like there would not
be an up and a down
in a situation like that there wouldn't
be a sky or a night or a day time you
know
but but that's happening obviously so
it doesn't make any sense you know
and then in one of them i think earth's
core it's just a constant cave system
there isn't an outdoors
well no there is there's a big cave
pocket where it's like outdoors with
glowing plants i think
yeah it's been a while since i've seen
it when there big frogs in there
yeah were they frogs or lizards or
something yeah i haven't seen it i got
to go back and see it again
yeah it's enjoyable but it doesn't make
a bit of [ __ ] sense well like i said
they're just fantastic movies not
supposed to yeah
don't ruin it too much by thinking about
it yeah exactly just watch it yeah just
enjoy
yeah the hard jaguar says the creators
of dark
made a new series called 1899 and is set
in a ship looks creepy i had heard
something about that it's like on
netflix yeah so i'm gonna probably be
watching that as well because i [ __ ]
loved dark it was so good
yeah tila put clash of the titans on the
list as well harry hamlin looks good in
the trailer yeah he made a good perseus
i just um my favorite part of clash of
the titans
is calabas yeah like i
he's i don't know why i just i just love
that whole thing with like the riddle
and like you know perseus go to like
turn himself invisible and going to
figure out what the riddle was and stuff
i love that sequence and the medusa
sequence obviously is [ __ ] awesome
yeah as well and um
hugh campbell says iron sky two has
nazis and a hollow earth
yeah but the the um the best one
though okay is the craziest one and it's
i have it on blu-ray
and it's got gary but gary busey's
gary busey that's the sun right yeah you
got gary busey in it no his son is jake
jake busy it's got it's got jake boosie
in it
and it's called nazis at the center of
the earth
nazis at the center of the earth is
[ __ ]
insane and what's the name of that
[ __ ] uh
crazy ass studio that makes it uh it's
asylum i think it's asylum and style
makes the crazy [ __ ]
just bad [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] action
movies
but this is actually their best one and
it does closely conform
to german to old german sci-fi concepts
it's got real saucers in it it's got
a hollow earth it's got things kind of
like not it kind of like nazi zombies
are in it
it's got i can't spoil all of it because
did they do frankenstein's army as well
frankenstein's army is a good one which
was kind of a similar
yeah kind of similar concept yeah you
need to see dead snow
that's a nazi zombie movie yeah
everybody was saying that yeah that's
it's great i haven't seen the i haven't
seen the um
the sequel but gee i want your first
awesome tila i want you to add your
playlist you will laugh your [ __ ]
asses off when me and jenny saw it for
the first time i didn't know anything
about the damn movie
but just as it kept going and it started
off pretty scary but as it kept going i
just we just started [ __ ]
rolling because it it gets more and more
ridiculous
but it's like no the nazis were talked
about that yeah they were going to do
that you know
everything that nazis were talking about
or all these
legends and [ __ ] that's what they
eventually show it it's
nazis at the center of the earth yeah
it's fun
it's fun mood yeah i mean one thing in
particular which i want yeah well you
can't spoil that [ __ ] but can't spoil it
one thing near the end is like my
favorite thing
right about the movie that made me laugh
the most as soon as it came up i'm just
like oh and we're doing this now all
right yeah
oh yeah yeah everything that they showed
i was going yeah
yeah yeah they were they were talking
about that
because it is very funny yeah the nazis
could dream they could dream big and all
of it comes true in this [ __ ] movie
yeah it's pretty hilarious yeah all
right so we've been going for an hour
you know that right yeah it's time to go
i'm kind of sleepy
because we i mean you know i kind of
slept in this morning but yeah you know
what happened last night
we went to you know we went to
mannequins
just a regular saturday night or
whatever and so we drank and whatnot
they were like oh you know getting kind
of hungry so we're gonna go to chantal's
then we go and then we sit and see
chantals but like nobody came and took
the order
so it's like i mean i know it was like
two or three in the morning but still
but we were just kind of like [ __ ]
i'm just i'm sick of waiting
so i said well let's stop at mcdonald's
uh
on the way home and then we stopped at
mcdonald's and we'd go in the
drive-through and they said we're all
we're doing cash only
yeah the cash only okay and i'm like no
no and i left who the [ __ ] gonna catch
what century is this nobody has cash
come on cash only at three o'clock in
the day i'm boring yeah it's like where
the [ __ ] am i supposed to get cash from
about this time of night
but yeah it's a ham and ham and so we
just came home and made a ham and egg
sandwich yeah
oh well at least we saved some money i
put it on french bread
[Laughter]
it was just of all the weird [ __ ] like
i'm like
somebody doesn't want us to eat anything
it says
i'm watching clash of the titans right
now i'm really appreciating the filming
locations along with special effects and
full
of course full of beautiful people yeah
full of beautiful people
that's the way those old movies were man
oh you're beautiful you're gonna put you
in the movies that's exactly
that was the thinking you paid to see
the goddamn movie put some pretty people
in the [ __ ] movie
yeah that the chinese said they won't
watch the [ __ ] american star wars or
american movies because the people are
too ugly they said that
they paid good money why are they
putting these ugly people in the [ __ ]
movie
we didn't pay ten dollars to sit here
and look at a bunch of ugly white people
yeah [ __ ] you know they know what a
good-looking people look like
and then they're like what this isn't
good-looking white people who's this
dude with a beard who's this old man
with a beard luke what
get that i don't know who mark hamill is
that's not what they paid they didn't
pay for that [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] they were [ __ ] brutal
and then they had
you know finn uh what's that guy who's
the actor for finn the black guy
british actor boyega yeah boy yeah john
boyega in the american poster he was
[ __ ] big big as everybody else for
the chinese poster they shrunk his ass
down to like the size of a dime
yeah they didn't want black people on
post
yeah yeah that's right and disney went
along with that [ __ ] yeah
well they just want the money man yeah
and then they're thinking they're
thanking the provinces the same
provinces for mulan the ones that had
the damn concentration camps
concentration camps and shrinking black
people that's [ __ ] disney right there
don't believe anything they [ __ ] say
don't believe anything those people say
those corporations don't give a [ __ ]
about you well no they just want money
it's about money
yeah that's the way it's always been yep
mango said uh yeah clash looks great on
blu-ray yeah it's it's just
i mean like i said i've seen it a
million million times so it's like i
never know how somebody that's never
seen it
is going to react to it because you know
i grew up with it and i loved it like
from a kid but i don't know like i just
think there's something about it that
the remake just didn't really capture
like you said i think the remake they
try and
they try too hard like with the cgi and
stuff to make everything look quote
unquote realistic and i just don't think
i don't i don't know i just don't think
that's the way to go yeah because they
try to make [ __ ] realistic but to me cgi
never looks realistic
so it's just kind of like a another
problem with these old classic movies
is that i've recommended okay like
here's a good example
i recommended uh conan one to uh xanada
but he looked at some shitty ass [ __ ]
transfer
probably off of vhs or something because
boy it looks terrible
there's a big difference in the quality
of what you saw in a theater and then
what you got on vhs and what you saw on
crt television and
bad if you get the blu-ray editions of
these or the hd
editions they're usually remastered and
they
look like they were supposed to look and
sometimes even better
than they looked in the movies uh like
for instance
there's a big difference between blu-ray
um flash gordon the the dela
de laurentiis flash gordon and and what
you saw on vhs
big difference well everything looked
like crap on vehicles it looked like
crap on vhs but on blu-ray it looked
gorgeous
now that everything's being like
remastered and yeah fixed up and
everything you can see
you know that it actually did look good
it's like you just thought it looked
cheap and shitty because you watched it
on vhs yeah on vhs they look like cheap
and shitty costumes when you see it on
blu-ray on big television you see all
the fine
weaves and the real expensive materials
that they used and the colors look so
much better
and the aspect ratio looks so much
better
looking
flash gordon is an acid trip it's an
acid trip to see that [ __ ] in hd
on a good tv i love that movie
yep but uh okay
you want to shut it down jenny it's time
like you're running out of steam yeah i
am just going to get really sleepy
you know what i mean like i said i you
know i i slept in but
right around this time starting to get
sleepy i probably need some coffee or
see
clash clash of titans on blu-ray might
be a good idea or at least written a
[ __ ] hd version of it
remastered version yeah well we can i
mean you know like i said we're gonna
watch uh i the tiger tonight
yeah and then we have to watch uh
we're gonna watch young frankenstein
because that's the movie that won
in the poll so that's the ones going up
uh thursdays friday
which i'm very excited about because i
[ __ ] love young frankenstein and i
was so excited to see that hulu had
added it
so that's the next one we're gonna do so
we're gonna watch those if we start
early i guess we could watch clash of
the titans too and talk about that [ __ ]
also but you know whatever
okay we'll see i like this we'll do a
whole ray harryhausen palooza
like over the next few days i want to go
back to [ __ ]
and [ __ ] uh at a time forgotten
people at time forgot want to see those
two
okay yeah i want to see them all again
yeah all right
so we will see you guys tomorrow at 3
p.m eastern standard time like i said
we're talking about eye of the tiger
maybe some other [ __ ] as well
so have a good rest of your weekend and
we'll see you guys tomorrow